okay so let's start with a quick review
of the previous lecture as usual so last
time we finished the discussion about uh
inertial uh navigation uh or
specifically dead reckoning technique
basically the problem setup is uh there
is a always a global reference frame or
a also called A World frame sometimes
which is a fixed coordinate system in
which you want to localize yourself okay
um
and then uh the the problem to solve
here is that uh the the types of
inertial sensors that we typically use
in robotics uh they have their own body
reference frame we call as a b and they
report the measurements in that
reference frame okay uh and that
reference frame is uh usually strapped
down to the the robot platform that the
sensor is mounted on and it just rotates
with the robot as a robot moves around
and and uh turns and rotates your SOB is
going to rotate relative to the fixed
Global reference frame so we need to
find basically a a transformation in
geometric transformation that can take
the measurements or readouts from the
sensor from its body reference frame to
the global frame and then we can
integrate those and do that Reckoning
right we also said that there's fancier
types of Imus called stable platform
which have these you know motorized
gimbals that stabilize and always align
the
basically the body frame with the global
frame so they basically
mechanically solve this this transform
for you but those are you know very
bulky and expensive and typically only
used in uh big you know military
vehicles and and and airplanes and
things like that for you know everyday
robotics uh almost always you're you're
working with a strap down type Imus so
the first step is orientation tracking
which is basically we need to find a
rotation Matrix we call it C sub G of T
so it's a Time varying 3D rotation
Matrix that essentially Maps your body
reference frame or derotates your body
reference frame to the global frame so
any measurement then you have say at a
acceleration measurement from your IMU
that's coming from uh coming in the body
reference frame you just multiply that
by the your rotation Matrix C sub G and
then it takes it to the global frame
right so the first step is to find this
and we did the the math we showed like
how from your uh gyroscope measurements
uh you can find and track this uh C sub
G Matrix so typically you start from a
known initial condition it can be
assumed or uh given from other sensors
and then once you have that over time at
each time step when
um a new uh gyroscope measurement
becomes available you multiply your
previous rotation Matrix C sub G by this
uh mini rotation Matrix which is given
by this Matrix exponential e to the
Delta Psi T So Delta Psi is a three by
three Matrix which basically has your
gyroscope readouts in it right so it has
the Omega X Omega Y and Omega z a range
in in this format inside it and again
remember that these omegas are coming in
in the body frame um right so so uh
that's why there's there's the so
subscript B for for all of them so it's
very simple right I mean the math was at
a little uh involved to get here but
once we actually solved everything uh
it's it's very clean right so you get at
every time step uh all your gyroscope
readouts you populate this Delta Psi
Matrix at time T you take the Matrix
exponential of it and if you are
implementing your algorithms in a
compute platform that doesn't support
Matrix exponentials we also derive this
more computationally efficient uh
basically formula for Delta Psi that I'm
not going to rewrite here but but but
you know what I'm talking about so that
Matrix exponential at each time step you
just evaluate that multiply it by your
previous uh uh body orientation Matrix
and that gives you basically that
updates your C uh to the latest and then
that that is your orientation tracking
step and then you can go to position
tracking and position tracking is all so
very simple so you start with your
accelerometer readout so it's a a vector
in R3 a sub B so it has the X Y and Z
component of the acceleration in the
body reference frame multiplied by C sub
G take that to the global frame
right so now we have accelerations in
the global fixed frame and then we just
need to integrate them uh so your first
integration goes from acceleration to
Velocity right uh we should remember to
subtract the gravity component of course
uh that's that's important uh in in 3D
if you're just doing 2D stuff and
everything is planar uh you can ignore
that if there's no basically Z component
to the acceleration measure but in 3D
like if you're working with a drone or
you know a a vehicle that can go up or
downhill it's very important to uh
subtract your gravity component it's a
fixed Vector always but you just need to
basically have it uh in the in the right
direction
um
and uh so you subtract that from your uh
measured acceleration in the global
frame
um and then multiply by delta T that's
your Delta velocity basically add that
to your previous velocity that's your
updated velocity at time t plus delta T
and same for position so your position
at time t plus delta T is there uh
previous position times velocity plus
velocity times delta T right so these
are just basically discrete discretized
integrals that that that we've written
here because always your your
measurements are coming uh over
discretized time at some update rate
okay any questions about this
thank you
okay uh very good and then he also
pointed out basically I mean this this
technique works really well and it's
almost always used but also uh it's it
has limitations basically uh the big
problem with pure inertial uh
localization is the drift problem right
because these sensor updates all have uh
offsets in them and noise but mainly the
offset as you integrate it causes
basically a drift that that that grows
unboundedly over time so
I think uh um we are all in a way kind
of familiar with this effect like uh
us humans as we walk around we're also
localizing ourselves and and we have
sensors in our body we have inertial
sensors like gyroscopes in our ears we
have visual sensors like our eyes and uh
if you ever have tried to walk with your
eyes closed you see you can go a few
steps through tons of steps on a
straight line but sooner or later you're
going to start drifting to one rear
ending the other and that's the exact
same problem part of it is the same
problem there's other uh reasons for us
not not being to you know walk perfectly
straight uh without high schools but
part of it is because when we are purely
doing uh inertial navigation with our
eyes closed we drift uh and then as soon
as we we open our eyes now our brain is
is doing basically a fusion between uh
the visual localization and the inertial
so it's it's doing what we call Visual
initial odometry Vio and that's much
much much more stable and accurate right
and that's effectively what is done in
robotics also so you always have
some contribution from your initial
sensors but you don't want to purely
rely on them you always mix in either
visual sensors or GPS or some other
sensor that doesn't drift and do some
type of Sensor Fusion and then you can
localize yourself without without drift
or with very very little drift
um okay any questions
all right so then we started talking
about uh
basically uh the the new chapter which
we are now starting to
um study sensors that are used for for
mapping right and we just uh we talked
about like uh different types of maps
there's offline maps and there's live or
online maps and uh they can be high
definition or high resolution or or low
resolution and you know all the
differences but now we are at this point
where we want to start uh looking at
sensors that that enable mapping for us
and uh specifically there's uh there's
four types of sensors uh so there's
there's sonar stands for sound
navigation and ranging and this is an
active sensor that sends uh out
basically uh uh acoustic ultrasonic
acoustic waves to the environment and
collects back the The Echoes and uses
those Echoes to basically generate a map
of the environment it's also called
ultrasonic sensor uh then there's radar
stands for radio navigation and ranging
and it's the same principle of operation
except you send a radio frequency
electromagnetic waves to the environment
you collect back the The Echoes and then
you process those Echoes to generate a
map then there is lidar stands for light
detection and ranging also sometimes uh
it's it's uh
said that it stands for light Imaging
detection and ranging
um so I don't think there's a consensus
on the on the abbreviation yet but
basically again it's the same principle
of operation but you're now sending uh
uh Optical wavelength uh electromagnetic
waves so the environment collect Back
The Echoes and then uh you build a map
based on that and finally we have
cameras which is a a based it like its
principle of operation is very different
from the other three it's not an active
sensor in the sense that it it sends an
active signal to the environment and
collects back Echoes it just collects
light from the environment and it could
be visible light and that's where you
get for instance the most common type of
camera which we call RGB camera but
there are other types of camera there
could be IR camera which collects
infrared sometimes also called thermal
cameras you can have more modern types
of camera like there's now this class of
cameras called dvs's or dynamic Vision
sensors also called event-based cameras
so they operate slightly differently
they are still based on visible light
but the type of signal they give you is
a little different so there's different
types of cameras but they all basically
uh collect some some type of you know
Optical signals from the environment and
then they process them and they give you
images right so we'll talk a little more
about this in a minute but fundamentally
uh unlike the the top three active
sensors cameras don't natively generate
maps for you they generate these
projections or images from the
environment but with some signal
processing and and computer vision
techniques you can generate maps from
camera signals
okay so again the principle operation of
the of the active sensors
is is all the same so and active again
is sonar radar and lidar so sensor
transmits a signal to the environment
the environment reflects back parts of
that signal as Echoes towards the sensor
and the sensor collects The Echoes and
does some signal processing on the
collected Echoes and then from that to
build a map you need to or the sensor
needs to determine or estimate two
things one is the range to The Targets
in the scene that reflected back Echoes
okay so you need to do some some range
estimation and you also need to estimate
the direction of the Targets in the
scene right because if it's just range
you can't build a map the map needs
range and and some angle information the
angle is it's called bearing also in
some contexts it's it's it's called
direction of arrival or DOA or angle of
arrival a08 these all for us they mean
the exact same thing it's just in
different literatures people use
different terminology for instance if
you if you read uh sonar or ultrasonic
literature bearing is usually the the
term used for for angle of arrival in
radar uh literature it's it's mostly
called DOA or direction of arrival
same thing but it's just basically the
the direction of corresponding to
different targets that are generating
Echoes uh back to the to the receiver
okay and then you repeat the process
basically that the sensor keeps you know
sending out uh some some type of a
signal to the environment collect the
Echoes process The Echoes to find range
and direction of arrival right and then
from range and direction of arrival
basically you can make a map or a point
cloud of of the scene as we'll see uh in
a second
um and and this can be 2D or 3D in the
2D case uh basically your direction of
arrival is typically just the Azimuth
angle right so you have no sensitivity
in elevation so it's kind of like a
flattened out map of the world and then
in the 3D case your direction of arrival
you get both Azimuth and elevation right
and then you can make a 3D Point Cloud
out of it
um so so this basically we talked about
range and bearing or direction of
arrival so these are basically the
minimum requirements that a sensor needs
to like the minimum
um things that the sensor needs to
measure or estimate such that it can
generate a map
um some sensors do more than that as
we'll see so for instance some sensors
also give you the velocity of the
targets uh based on some some Physics of
the signals or some other attributes of
the Target and those are more advanced
sensors but range and bearing angle is
the minimum that essence or that is
useful for robotic mapping needs to
needs to do as we'll see any questions
about this
okay so uh here's like a picture of how
the process of of mapping the
environment works here we're looking at
a point cloud from a lidar but the the
general concept again is the same for
all these uh different types of active
sensors so basically the point Cloud
we're looking at here it's it's it's a
collection of a bunch of points right
they're closely packed so they look like
kind of like uh straight uh or curved
lines but it's a collection of points
and if you look at every Point basically
the the back end process that has
happened is that the receiver has uh
transmitted a signal towards that
receive back the Echo and from the echo
it has estimated the range to that point
we call that rho sub k for the case
point so there's a there's a range and a
direction of arrival which in this case
it's a 3D basically Point Cloud so the
direction of arrival consists of two
angles there is an Azimuth angle Theta
and an elevation angle Phi right so for
every Point basically there's three
parameters that the the receiver has
estimated and then from those you
basically or the receiver can put all
those points uh in a common reference
frame and generate a 3D Point Cloud
right and you see like to get a dense
map like this this process needs to
happen possibly millions of times right
we're looking at millions of points
probably in this one picture
um and and that's how these sensors
operate like the modern ones can can
process
millions of points per second very fast
and and basically detect the range and
the direction of arrival to all of those
and then visualize all of them in a in a
common coordinate system and give us
this very detailed basically Point
clouds and then the process can happen
tens of times per second then you get
these high frame rate basically live
maps that are that are generated uh
uh so is this is this concept of of like
a app or a point cloud Clear like how
what needs to happen to generate okay
now uh in terms of the performance of
this stuff of these types of sensors so
again we said that the principle of
operation is almost identical between
sonar radar and lidar okay but the
performance of the the sensor is is is
is vastly different as as we'll see and
and when we talk about sensor
performance
um depending on the application
different uh parameters of the sensor
output might be more or less important
to you but typically the performance
like the key attributes of the sensor
that are are important for robotic uh
autonomy applications are these four
factors that are listed here one is uh
basically what is the maximum range that
far can you see with this sensor and at
what resolution right so what is the
minimum range difference between two
Targets that your sensor can
discriminate that is your range
resolution and what is the maximum
detectable range that's one factor that
goes into the performance of your system
then there is the field of view and
angular resolution so field of view I
think it's clear what it means like how
wide you can you can map basically and
it could be in both Azimuth and
elevation so you typically give two
angles for the field of view and then
the angular resolution is basically what
is the minimum angular separation
between two Targets that your sensor can
discriminate so let's say you have a a
person standing next to a car or a wall
or something how close can they be
for your sensor to still be able to
detect there's two different targets in
there uh that's that's another measure
of the sensor performance then there's
measurement rate so how fast are you
getting measurement updates either in
terms of points or frames of a point
cloud like however your sensor is
reporting how fast is that uh
basically update coming
and finally there is this uh con concept
of dynamic range which is basically uh
the the ratio of the strongest to the
weakest Target and that that your sensor
in one scene that your sensor can
measure so dynamic range perhaps the
best way or the most familiar way that
that you have experienced it is with
with cameras you know if you for
instance Point your camera to a bright
Sky
um you you either can get you know the
details in the highlights and Shadows of
the sky and then things that are on the
ground uh become kind of washed out or
if you focus it on the ground you can
get you know the details of highlights
and Shadows on the on the ground and
then your your Sky basically uh becomes
uh watch that that's because of the
limited dynamic range of the camera
other types of sensors basically have
the same limitation you don't get
infinite dynamic range you always have
some some ratio of you know know the
brightest to the darkest Target and then
this concept of brightness and and
darkness is tied to the physics of how
you're measuring so invisible light it's
very clear what we mean by bright and
dark but uh for instance when your
sensor is measuring acoustic waves this
idea of bright and dark that is
basically how much of the acoustic wave
that material reflects back to you the
material that absorbs a lot of the
acoustic wave that is quote-unquote dark
for a sonar sensor and a material that
reflects back a lot of the acoustic wave
that's a bright material for a sonar and
that ratio so what is like the the
maximum ratio of the of the very strong
Target to the weak Target that is the
dynamic range of of your sensor so of
course we always want the the the the
the best of all of these right so we
want sensors with very high range range
super high resolution very wide field a
few very high angular resolution super
fast measurement rates and very high
dynamic range and you're never going to
get that there's always trade-offs
between these yes
what is the way is the detectable
outcomes because is that like at a
sensor level physics level or like after
signal processing we can deny it and
then we can see some apples that's a
that's a great question so I'm just
going to repeat it so the question is
when we say uh weakest detectable Echoes
at what level are we talking about is it
physics level is it at you know the
sensing front end is it after the DSP so
typically uh when we talk about sensor
performance we're talking at system
level okay so that's basically at the
very output after everything has
happened you know so after your physics
has happened you've received the echo
you have digitized it you've done your
DSP on it denoising in all the
algorithms that you can run and then you
get what you get which is a point cloud
and and in that point Cloud what is the
weakest Target that you can you can
distinguish so uh and that's a great
question because it's basically a segue
into this this uh little note here which
is all of these performance metrics
these are very complex functions of many
things it's a function of the physics of
the sensor you know what kind of for
instance signals it's sending it's a
function of the actual waveforms that
you transmit you know are we doing for
instance some fancy digital waveforms or
analog waveforms or other things it's a
it's a function of your Hardware
architecture you know how how low noise
your amplifiers are or have you done
anything you know clever with the
hardware architecture and it's a
function of the signal processing
algorithms that you're using so all of
these are factored in and at the end of
the day at the system level you get a
map or a point cloud and then on that
point Cloud you judge basically the the
the these performance metrics of the of
the sensor and because it's such a
complex function
um you know it's uh the that's part of
the reason why these different sensors
active sensors although the principle of
operation is essentially the same you
get vastly different performance from
them because they have different physics
they have different Hardware they have
different waveforms they have different
signal processing algorithms associated
with them also for the same reason
that's why this you know
field of sensing for autonomy is still
such an active field because there is
lots of opportunities to improve the
performance on all different fronts from
you know the physics to the hardware to
the signal processing algorithms as we
get better and better and better with uh
with these we get better and better
performance out of the out of the
sensors
um
okay so here is a very very high level
and also not super scientific uh
comparison of the sensor performance on
on on different metrics and the reason I
say it's not super scientific is because
uh first of all each of these basically
uh uh parameters that we're looking here
for instance you're looking at range
resolution speed cost and the compute
required for these different sensors
each of them there's a huge variance
around it because there is no single you
know standard way of doing sensing each
each sensor each manufacturer they have
their own Hardware they have their own
you know signal processing algorithms so
the way you should
first of all I mean don't read too much
into this this is supposed to just give
you a high level you know sense of what
to expect on average today from
different sensors and again sensors are
you know over time getting better and
better and if somebody were to you know
redo this table in 10 years it might
look quite different from what I have
here but at a high level what you get uh
is uh in terms of range for instance
sonar has has a typically very short
range and then your lighter and
radar can can sense long range and just
to give you a sense by short range and
sonar we mean like less than 10 meters
long range for lidar radar we mean
hundreds of meters and then for camera
medium range it means a few tens of
meters probably right and again that is
today these numbers are going to change
and get better for all sensors over time
resolution against sonar is low lidar
can be very high radar is medium it's
getting a lot better I think soon radar
is going to be high also and Camera as
we know can be very high and also even
camera I mean digital cameras have been
around for tens of years but they're
still getting better and better as as
time goes by
um so I don't want to again spend too
much time on this but here you kind of
get a sense of why these sensors are
complementary there's none of them where
like you know everything is is is is is
green and and great they all have their
own you know uh performance limitations
and that is part of the reason uh to get
a high level of autonomy if you want to
you know cover a wide range of use cases
in very challenging conditions you need
to use uh multiple sensors also looking
at this it kind of explains you know why
today a lot of commercial
autonomy Solutions are heavily driven by
camera you know I mean camera has a lot
of good things right you can get very
good resolution it can be very high
speed cost is low right and you get
decent range out of it so you know if
you were to just pick one today it makes
a lot of sense to go for for a camera
now you see that compute requirement for
camera is pretty high and that goes back
to my the point I made earlier which is
cameras don't natively produce maps for
you they give you images which are
projections of uh the the world out
there so you need to use computer vision
techniques to generate maps from cameras
and there's two big classes of uh you
know how you can do essentially mapping
with with cameras so the big problem to
solve is that when you look at an image
frame from a camera there is no depth
information in it right because of that
projection operation depth is entirely
lost so you don't you can't get you know
range to different targets you look at
the frame and you can see oh there's a
tree and a person and a car
but you cannot immediately tell what is
the distance to the car or the tree or
the person and that's a big problem that
you need to solve to do proper mapping
with cameras and it's a very complex
problem to solve and that's why it needs
a high level of of computation to to
basically do that to undo the projection
operation uh and and produce a 3D
basically map from a camera and there's
two main types of uh you know basically
depth estimation techniques for for
cameras uh one big class is called
monocular and as the name suggests it
only uses a single camera
and uh monocular depth estimation uh it
used it is used a lot today but you need
to know that monocular depth estimation
or mde there is no physics principle
behind it like if you only have one
camera
there is no
way of you know no physics that enables
you to undo that projection operation
that depth information is completely
lost for good right but somehow by the
magic of of neural Nets if you you know
throw enough data at a big DNN it
eventually learns to estimate depth for
you from monocular images and it does a
very well job but it is important to
note that any technique that does mde is
pure hallucination right and and and
that means there's there's a risk factor
there because we we don't know like in
some you know unseen situation what
would that Network do nevertheless these
are extremely useful and again
um us humans we do that too if we close
one of our eyes which is one eye open we
can still do you know pretty decent
depth estimation it's not perfect but in
most situation it situations it works
fine then for stereo and that's when you
have two cameras with some distance
which is called the Baseline and then by
capturing two frames from two cameras of
the same scene which are not co-located
you can estimate depth and do mapping
and in Stereo Vision then there is real
physics that's like how our eyes work
because you're looking at
um basically the the scene from two
different points and then by doing some
geometry like triangulation you can
estimate depth so stereo Vision uh
that's not hallucination that's you know
there's real physics behind it
and for stereo depth estimation also
there is you know very principled
algorithms based on you know Optics and
geometry and there is some
learning based algorithms and more
modern ones actually do a little bit of
both they do a little bit of learning
bass plus a little bit of more uh
principled algorithms but again the high
level point is you can do mapping with
cameras and you can't generate you know
3D Point clouds it needs a high level of
computation if you do it with a single
camera the the caveat is that at the end
of the day you're hallucinating and and
there's a risk involved if you do it
with two or more cameras like Siri
Vision then there's there's real physics
behind it and and typically no no
hallucination involved any questions
okay so we're going to start basically
going in depth about sonar and then
we'll talk about radar and lidar in a
couple weeks but right now the topic of
discussion is is sonar
so as we said principle of operation is
is pretty simple right you have some
some emitter it emits a
ultrasonic acoustic wave it hits a
Target and then the target generates an
echo that reflects back towards uh your
sensor and then a receiver receives that
that Echo and uh based on the time of
flight principle that we learned as we
were studying GPS if the if you can
measure that time of flight from that
you can estimate range right so range is
is rho here one thing to note is that
the relationship between your your range
and your time of flight
um is you should account for basically
the round trip delay right so if if your
total time of flight is Tau that is your
forward path and the return path time of
flight right so that's the full round
trip time of flight and because of that
when you want to convert that to range
you want to divide Top by two and then
multiply it by the velocity of the wave
right so that's why there is a there's a
factor of uh one half there compared to
the GPS the GPS was one way right your
transmitter was transmitting the
receiver was receiving it was just a
one-way travel for active sensing your
transmitter and receiver are co-located
and then your signal does a full round
trip so that's why there is a factor of
of one half so that's how ranging works
for any active sensor basically
here in this picture we don't see how
bearing or direction of arrival
estimation works we'll talk about that
in a bit but for now we're going to
start basically by studying the physics
of the acoustic waves and and
specifically this transmitted wave how
how is how does that look you know what
is the physics of it how is it related
to the geometry of the of the emitter
and and so on okay so let's let's start
by uh basically talking about what is an
acoustic wave so because waves are
basically pressure waves that travel in
different materials they can travel in
solids or liquids or gases and basically
what the wave is is this periodic
patterns of high and low pressure in the
in in the material so you you have
basically compression points in the
material which uh is is basically a high
pressure point and then you have uh
basically uh rarefaction points which is
a low pressure point and it periodically
basically repeats in the material and
travels at some uh uh speed uh V the
wavelength
of the wave is the distance between two
peaks or two high pressure points and
you also have the frequency of your
acoustic wave which uh basically is
related to the speed V and the
wavelength Lambda by this equation so
frequency is uh velocity over over
Lambda basically
um audible sound for instance the
frequency as you might know is between
20 Hertz and 20 kilohertz
an ultrasound is anything above 20
kilohertz so above audible frequencies
that's what ultrasonic
wavelengths are and that's what is is is
used for for sensing typically now one
thing to note is that and this is a
source of big complication when it comes
to acoustic sensors
sonar sensors is that the speed of sound
depends on material properties so it
depends on for instance the density of
the material even for air it depends on
the temperature
of air also it depends on the humidity
level of air so it does vary quite a bit
so for instance just the temperature
dependency can be approximated by this
equation here so your your T Sub C is
the temperature in degree C so t plus
273 that's your absolute temperature in
kelvin's and as you see there's a square
root there so
generally speaking uh your sonar sensor
does not know the you know all the
material properties of the medium in
which the acoustic wave is is
propagating so it just makes an
assumption for what we is for some
nominal conditions and if the actual
conditions are much different like if
the temperature is much higher than what
was assumed or the humidity level is
very different that V is going to change
and as we know from the time of flight
equation that is going to cause an error
in your range estimate right so so
that's just one thing to note the other
thing to note is
sound velocity compared to for instance
electromagnetic waves is very very low
right like this number V in nominal
conditions say like I don't know like at
at 25 degrees C temperature is around
330 meters per second I think 330 340
meters per second which is a million
times a slower almost and the speed of
light or speed of electromagnetic waves
okay so this is one of the reasons if we
go back to our comparison table
up here
that's for instance why we say sonar
speed is very low I mean that's just
from the physics of it sound waves
travel very slowly compared to
electromagnetic rays and that is going
to be a big limitation for when it comes
to to sensing as we'll see uh so so uh
right off the bat you know the physics
of of acoustic waves you know impose
some some big limitations on on what
your sensor can and cannot do
okay
um
now the behavior of These acoustic waves
is governed by the wave equation uh
which is which is given uh here and or
the wave equation is is that we have
this parameter P which is a function of
position R and time T and that's the
acoustic pressure in the medium okay and
what the acoustic pressure is is the
local deviation from the from the
ambient uh basically pressure in the
material so it can be positive or
negative based on if there's like
compression or refraction in the
material and the wave equation basically
what it is it's the laplacian of P so
that's this term which is basically the
sum of the second derivatives with
respect to X Y and Z so if R is our
position
Vector at some point in space we are
measuring that pressure so it's the XYZ
vector and then the laplacian is given
by the sum of the second derivatives
minus one over velocity squared times
the second derivative with respect to
time is equal to zero so this is a very
famous you know a wave equation in
physics and it's for any type of wave I
mean you you look at you know
electromagnetic waves it's basically the
same equation instead of acoustic
pressure then it's your electric field
amplitude and then instead of V you put
in the speed of light and then that's
your basically wave equation in
electromagnetics so this is basically
equation we need to solve to find what
the acoustic wave that is traveling in
the medium is what this the sensor
transmits to the medium uh is is
determined by by this equation the
solution depends on the shape or the
geometry of the aperture that is
generating the acoustic wave so that
aperture for instance the simplest one
is is an audio speaker right the speaker
that you know cone shape thing typically
that's the aperture that's vibrating and
generating uh the the sound wave so the
shape and geometry of it uh is is a big
factor that determines the solution and
also the boundary conditions and the
vibration pattern okay
the vibration pattern we're going to
start simple and assume our emitter is
just vibrating at a fixed constant
frequency so it's just generating a pure
tone basically of of acoustic wave so in
that case if you have single frequency
vibration your your time dependence of
your pressure uh is it's just you know
just a harmonic term which we write as e
to the J 2 pi f t where f is the
frequency of the you know of the of the
vibration of the emitter okay again
we're working with complex exponentials
here remember that the physical
Solutions are just a real part of it
okay so that time dependency is is easy
uh the position dependency is the is the
more complicated part that we need to
figure out now it turns out that for
very simple uh aperture geometries for
the for the emitter uh we can have very
simple solutions for the uh for the
acoustic wave the simplest one is if you
have like an infinite plane you know at
an infinite plane that is vibrating at
some uh frequency f it will generate
what we call uh plane waves okay and the
plane wave solution is given by this
expression here as you see your P of uh
R and T there's some a that's the
amplitude times e to the J minus K dot R
we'll talk about this in a second but
that's your time dependency that we
talked about 2 pi ft that's just you
know that pure harmonic oscillation what
this K dot R is K is what we call a wave
vector and what the wave Vector is is a
vector with an amplitude that is 2 pi
over the wavelength okay and a direction
that is uh given by this unit vector k
hat and K hat is determines the
direction of the propagation of these
plane waves
and so basically what happens in the
case of a emitter that is this infinite
planar surface that is vibrating your
waves acoustic waves are also like the
surfaces of constant pressure are also
infinite planes and they all propagate
in a direction that is determined by
this k-hat vector and that K hat is
basically the the vector that is normal
to the aperture that is that is
generating the wave I'll show you a
picture in a second to to clarify this
but um big thing to to note is this term
k dot R that's the inner product of your
wave Vector with the position at which
you're looking at the the pressure and
um from from linear algebra we know that
when you have a fixed vector k k dot r
the points on which K dot R is is
constant they determine a they Define a
plane right that's the definition of a
plane in in linear algebra so it should
make sense that this this equation
basically gives you this planar geometry
for the waves
another very simple emitter geometry
that we can solve the wave equation for
analytically is a point source so if you
have this infinitesimal small point that
is just like vibrating in place at some
frequency f it generates what we call
spherical waves and spherical waves the
equation for the acoustic pressure is is
is given here here as you see the
amplitude is not constant it's a over R
and that's kind of like because of the
conservation of energy as the spherical
wave spherical wave propagates in every
direction right so the energy gets you
know spread out as as it uh propagates
and that's why you have like a one over
R here e to the J 2 pi f t is there
that's just our you know time dependency
that is always the same and then in the
exponent you have uh your your wave
number Norm K times Norm R right so note
that the difference between the plane
wave in in the plane wave case we had K
dot r that was the vector inner product
here we just have the multiplication of
Norm K times Norm R Norm K times Norm
Norm K is a constant so so remember Norm
of K is always 2 pi over Lambda so this
term if I were to rewrite it uh just the
the position dependency of it is minus J
2 pi over Lambda times Norm of R right
for this to be constant that means Norm
of R should be constant right there's
there's not everything else is constant
so normal for our constant that's that's
a sphere right so that's why the the
surfaces of constant pressure in this
case Define spheres and those are
spherical ways before I show you the
pictures to clarify
note that both of these types of waves
of plane waves and and this perfect
spherical waves these are not physically
possible to generate in the like the
ideal versions of them we can get close
to them why they're not possible because
those emitter geometries are not
physically possible we can't have you
know an infinitesimal Point as a
acoustic wave Source we also can't have
an infinitely big plane as an acoustic
wave Source nevertheless these are you
know a good start to understand you know
how waves work and
um kind of making our way towards more
realistic geometries so here's the
picture so in this case on the left you
see uh the the plane wave so this black
line is basically the source it extends
to Infinity right so it's an infinite
plane and then the waves that are
generated basically that's the K Vector
that is perpendicular to the to the
source determines the direction of the
travel of the wave and then as you see
these surfaces of constant pressure are
just line uh planes that's why it's
called a plane wave and um
uh you know points of the same pressure
as as we know our wavelength apart for
the spherical case your source is just a
tiny Dot
uh oscillating at at and physically
oscillating right this is sound waves at
uh frequency uh F and then it generates
these uh waves with uh surface constant
pressure surfaces that are spherical I'm
not I'm just showing a cross section
here so these are really you know
propagating in in three dimensions in
every direction and our pressure at a
point R is given by by this uh
expression
one thing that we did not account for
[Music]
uh wave propagation acoustic wave
propagation in any medium is lossy right
and by lossy I mean some of the wave
energy uh gets dissipated as heat as and
that's because of the viscosity of the
of the medium as it propagates right
that is not factored in here you know
this a we just take it to be a constant
right but it turns out that the
amplitude itself
drops
because of the uh of the lossiness of
the of the media and the the uh
basically that that attenuation uh
factor is modeled but by what is called
the stokes's law of sound attenuation so
it turns out that in in reality the a
itself which is the amplitude
drops exponentially worth range so our
Norm of R is you know how far away you
are from your Source or your emitter
um and then you get this exponential
decay which is e to the minus Alpha
times R and Alpha is your attenuation
factor for the uh for the wave Alpha Alf
pens on a number of parameters of the
medium so it's given in the stokes's law
by this expression here there's a lot in
there but most of these are just
material properties for instance ETA is
is what is called the dynamic viscosity
coefficient
rho is the medium density V in the
denominator is the is the wave speed so
speed of sound basically the really
important one is is this F squared
factor in the in the in the numerator so
our attenuation Factor grows with the
square of the wave frequency right so
the higher the frequency you get more
attenuation as as it propagates and this
is for instance the main reason
um sometimes you're you know walking on
the street and there's loud music
playing inside a building or in a car
that's driving by and you hear the bass
right you hear the beat but you don't
hear the high frequency content of the
music typically and that's because the
high frequency content according to
stokes's law will attenuate much much
faster the low frequency content which
is the base that doesn't attenuate as
much and that's usually what we hear
when we are far away from from a source
of music right
so um here's a plot of basically actual
measured attenuation factor for acoustic
waves in air these were measured in uh
25 degrees C air and you have many
Curves in here and that's because the
measurement has been done for different
uh basically humidity levels relative
humidity levels in in the air from zero
percent all the way to 100 percent
relative humidity and as you know
humidity affects the the of course the
viscosity but also the the the sound
travel of uh in in the air so that's why
you get different attenuation curves
basically for different
um humidity levels high level as you see
and this here there's a line which is
our our stokes's law basically that's
that's the line right and as you see I
mean yes at super low frequencies the
actual measured values deviate quite a
bit from the store sales law but at
higher frequencies they get all pretty
close to uh basically this dose's law
and note that both axes the frequency
and the alpha attenuation are
logarithmic in this plot okay I mean
stokes's law looks like a line but
that's because we're plotting it in a
log log scale
now when it comes to what frequencies we
use for uh sonar and Robotics as I said
it starts at 20 kilohertz which is right
above the audible frequencies and
normally we go up to about 150 kilohertz
or so
that's the range that is used for sonar
in robotics
and in this range if you look at your
attenuation levels you know from the
stokes's law you know it's it's from 10
to the minus 2 to 10 to the zero right
that's that that's the range of
attenuation that you get in this
frequency range and it is a lot it is it
is really really a lot and this is again
why if you refer back to the high level
comparison table I showed you a few
minutes back we said that the maximum
range for sonar is low it could
typically see up to like 10 or maybe 15
meters and that's again dictated by the
physics of acoustic waves at these
frequencies you get a very very high
attenuation Factor so you just don't
collect back enough energy from the the
targets that are far away from you
because of this attenuation Factor yes
what are the percents mean on the plot
these are humidity levels so the
measurement was has done
um at different relative humidity levels
in air so zero percent is you know
completely dry air and 100 is the
maximum humidity that the air can can
sustain at 27 degrees C
okay so again just we haven't like
talked about you know the sensor
architecture or you know the DSP or
anything like that yet but just by
studying the physics we kind of know
what to expect from a a sonar sensor so
it's going to be slow and that's because
the sound travel is a slow comparatively
slow with you know compared to radar and
lidar because
electromagnetic waves travel million
about a million times faster and it's
also not going to have a ton of range
because of high attenuation factor in
the air okay nevertheless it's an
extremely useful sensor we just need to
know its its limitations when we're
studying it uh okay so uh when it comes
to what acoustic frequency you want to
choose for your sensor there is a big
trade-off as we just learned from
stokes's law lower frequencies attenuate
less right so that means it helps with
the maximum range that you can sense
but uh on the other hand higher
frequencies increase the angular
resolution and we'll see how we have I'm
uh showed you how and why uh but but
that's a big trade-off right so you want
higher frequencies for better resolution
but that means you're going to lose
range and then that's a that's a
trade-off that I mean it's it's kind of
like a design parameter that you know as
somebody designs a sensor they need they
need to study this trade-off and find
you know for this application what is
the right uh frequency to choose based
on the resolution requirements and the
maximum range requirements that they
have so some examples as I as I said for
robotic sonar in air right because you
can also do sonar in in water as as as
as as you might know it's actually very
common to do sonar in in water and the
numbers change right because water is a
very different medium the sound is
different your attenuation factors are
are different velocity is different so
so here the numbers are for air okay but
the frequencies that are used are
between 20 and 120 or 150 kilohertz
typically
and with that you get about a range of
10 meters again these numbers are not
set in stone right like you might find
somebody who is doing
sonar and air at I know two or three
hundred kilohertz and that's fine or
somebody might come up with clever
signal processing techniques to see 20
or 30 meters but these are you know
ballpark numbers like for sure with
sonar at these frequencies in there you
cannot see 100 meters or 200 meters
that's for sure and the angular
resolution kind of you know that that
you can expect is about you know less
than a degree like I've seen as low as
0.2 or 0.1 degrees not not much less
than that
now as you know uh sonar Imaging is also
extremely common in medical applications
right
in medical ultrasound
um so so that's basically the images
called sonograms they use very different
frequencies so the frequencies are much
much higher they're in the megahertz
range so almost like a thousand times
higher than what we use in in robotic
applications and because of that
according to stokes's law they're going
to get a much much higher attenuation
but that is fine because in medical
applications you only need to see you
know the inside of a body so as long as
you can penetrate a few inches you're
good and that's actually the maximum
range that they get they only get a few
inches but they get much much much
higher resolution because they're
operating at a higher frequency and I
mean I've I've I don't know if you have
seen the latest you know latest and
greatest in in sonograms I mean they're
amazing they can reconstruct that and
the organs in the body in 3D with
extremely high detail and and that's by
basically by the physics of you know
operating at high frequencies and also
doing very good signal processing uh on
the on the signals that we receive in
robotics unfortunately I mean inches is
not useful we need you know at least you
know a few meters so that's why we
operate at lower frequencies and we pay
the price of basically not having the
best resolution
any questions
yes
you generate a wave a frequency that's
below the audible
range reviewers so you can get interest
range uh you can you would need to
basically be below 20 Hertz so it's
going to be you know a very
very low frequency
and and you can get long range but you
get very poor very very poor resolution
with that so it might or might not be
useful depending on what the application
is I have not seen that I should say
like operating at such low frequencies
some animals do I think but for robotics
I have not seen that
also there's some practical issues you
know you typically need you know big
drivers for such low frequencies and
things like that but yeah in principle
it should be possible
yeah
okay so
um
we looked at basically uh two idealized
cases of of uh acoustic waves it was the
plane waves and spherical waves and we
said that these are mathematically
interesting because uh we can we can
solve the the wave equation analytically
basically for those types of emitters
but in reality the the the emitters that
we work with for sensing um are
different and and we need to find the
solutions to the wave equations for
those types of emitters a specific most
common
color I mean it's like a disc basically
or a piston that vibrates in in place uh
and so they have finite size and they're
basically mostly just just round you
know circular disks so we need to you
know basically solve our uh wave
equation for that type of emitters to to
get a more realistic uh um uh basically
understanding of of what type of
acoustic waves we're dealing with
um and the way we can do that is uh
using uh so if you want to find
basically the the beam pattern that is
generated by a finite size circular disk
that is vibrating we can use a principle
and from Optics which is called the
hoihens fresnel principle
um
what it says basically
um I'm going to skip over the words and
just show you the picture because I
think it's it's easier to understand so
let's say you have so this this blue
disc here is your emitter or the
aperture that is vibrating to generate
an acoustic wave for you so it's a
finite size Round Disc and it's some in
its some plane x uh the coordinates are
in X Prime y Prime you know axes it's in
a plane and uh we have some observation
point in the 3D space in which we want
to find what is the acoustic pressure
that is generated by that emitter and
what the hoyens fresnel principle says
uh basically is you can break down this
emitter whatever the shape is here ours
is is a circular disk but whatever it is
you can break it down into small points
right is going to be an infinite number
of them but you can you know decompose
it to small points and each point uh
would then be generating as we know a
spherical wave for you right so if you
basically sum or integrate an infinite
number of spherical waves that are
generated by all the points on your
aperture and sum their contribution all
up at your point of observation that
gives you the actual solution to your
wave equation or the actual wave that
you would measure at that point is the
concept clear
so it's basically like a superposition
type principle right you just look at
the geometry of your aperture you
integrate over all the points on the
aperture surface and then each point is
basically generating a spherical wave
here that travels and we have the exact
expression for these spherical waves and
then you just sum them up
all of those at your point of
observation and that gives you what your
acoustic wave is the principle again is
from the Optics so if you have like an
optical Source you could do the same as
rule C for instance when you study
lidars but it's for any type of you know
wave basically the same principle can be
applied now now it turns out that you
can do further simplifications on top of
the hohense frenel principle the first
simplification that you can do is that
if if the distances that you're
interested in are much larger than a
wavelength you can do your first
simplification and that simplification
is called the frenel kirchhoff basically
approximate integral and for sensing
this is always the case I mean Lambda
for for ultrasound acoustic waves I mean
these are where we're talking about like
less than less than an inch or so so
you're always you know interested in in
things that are almost always interested
in things that are further away and then
we can basically approximate the Hoist
fresnel integral by by this integral so
what this is let's break it down this is
just a constant right one over J Lambda
and then the integral is done over the
The Source aperture so basically over
our circular disk in our case or
whatever the geometry is what we're
looking at circular apertures right now
and what we're integrating is this P of
R Prime is that's the acoustic wave
amplitude
on at the source right so R Prime is the
coordinate
of the points on the on the aperture
that is vibrating so P of R Prime is
known right because that's where we're
generating basically that's the source
and then this term here e to the minus J
Norm K row over rho rho is the distance
from
um if I go one slide back rho is the
distance between a point on the source
and our point of observation that's the
distance row so that's R Prime on the
source R is our point of observation and
they have some distance row and there's
an angle Theta uh between them or
between the plane of the source and your
point of observation so this term here
is that's basically your spherical wave
right that is that is generated at point
R Prime and has traveled a distance row
to get to your observation point and
then there's this cosine Theta term
which is Theta is the basically the the
angle between the emitter plane and your
observation Point are okay
okay good I mean this is okay you can
numerically you know solve this integral
and find your your uh acoustic pressure
at the point R but we want we want
something simpler to work with something
that you know is is analytical and then
helps us you know to gain some intuition
into how how uh uh the the acoustic wave
propagates in the space so there's one
more level of approximation you can do
on on top of the frenel kirchhoff and
that's a again if you're looking at even
further distances so if you're looking
at what is called the far field which is
distances row that are much greater than
a squared over Lambda over a is the
radius of this circular aperture so the
aperture or the emitter if it has a
radius a if you're looking at distances
which are much greater than a squared
over Lambda which again it's called far
field and the term might you know
suggests that oh this means you know you
need to be tens of meters away no
actually if you're two inches away
you're already in the far field or maybe
sometimes even one inch away I mean if
you plug in numbers of you know what
realistic uh dimensions and wavelengths
are you would see that it's called far
field but it's physically not that far
so we are almost always in the far field
regime when it comes to to sensing okay
so then you can further simplify your
fresnel kirchhoff integral so basically
what happens is that in the previous
slide we had this you know cosine Theta
term that becomes almost equal to one
because you're so far away and then you
can do some approximation on what rho is
at the at the far field and after you
apply those approximations your integral
reduces to what is called the the front
Hofer equation
and this is what it is so you still have
some some constant okay which is depends
on rho the distance Lambda and Kappa is
just some face factor that comes out of
the integral and then what you have this
P of X Prime y Prime is again is the
acoustic pressure at the source at some
point x Prime y Prime on top on on your
aperture okay so it's known times this
complex exponential okay which is e to
the minus J uh Norm K the wave Vector
times x Prime X Plus y Prime y over Z
okay X and Y
are your coordinates of the XYZ is the
coordinates of the point of observation
and X Prime y Prime is the is the
coordinates of your point on the source
over which you're integrating so we're
summing up over all X Prime y primes
again because we need to add the
contributions of all the points on the
source and then we're observing what the
pressure is at some point with
coordinates X Y and Z so if I just
rearrange this plugin 2 pi over Lambda 4
Norm K I get what is at the bottom so
all that changed from the top row to the
bottom is is this complex term here
right so again I've plugged in Norm k
equals 2 pi over Lambda
and I've taken Lambda into the the sum
and just kept the 2 pi here if you look
at this here
a little bit it should become obvious
that what you have in this integral is
just a Fourier transform it's a 2d for
your transform but it's a Fourier
Transformer the list specifically if you
wanted to become more more obvious we
can rename the variables so you can call
X over Lambda Z call that uh
PSI and your y over Lambda Z called that
ETA and then it's it's basically a
Fourier transform of your p x Prime y
Prime I mean in One D if I have some
function P of X Prime
what is the Fourier transform of it for
a transform of X Prime is integral
p x Prime e to the minus J 2 pi f x
Prime d x Prime right
this is the definition of the force I
mean there might be a constant here that
I've forgotten I don't know 2 pi or 1
over 2 pi or something but the main
thing is that this integral is the is is
the Fourier transform right uh same
thing here we have the exact same thing
except it's in 2D so this is a really
really powerful beautiful result which
tells you your far field basically
radiation or acoustic wave uh is is uh
related to the geometry of your Source
via a Fourier transform and the exact
same principle right away applies in
Optics also if you have a study whether
it's called there is a field called
Fourier Optics which is all based on
this basically it tells you if you're
looking at Optics at the far field the
relationship to the source is basically
just a Fourier transform okay
basically beam pattern or radiation
pattern we need to find the 2D foyer
transform of a circular disk so
specifically what we have are P of X
Prime y Prime which is the wave we're
generating at the source is a constant
a0 inside the circle
if the circle has radius a so when X
Prime squared plus y Prime squared is is
less than a so that's inside the disk we
have
at the source at the emitter we have
some acoustic pressure a0 and outside
it's zero okay that's the definition of
a emitter that is a circular disk and
and then we need to basically find the
2d40 transform of this function so you
plug it into your integral the a0 of
course comes out so you just need to
basically evaluate this integral and it
turns out that you can do that almost
analytically the result is given here
that's the famous 2D four-year transform
of a circular disk if you're interested
and you know how exactly this is derived
there's a link in the notes that you can
look but at high level what you get is
an expression where the dependency on on
the distance between your observation
point and the source is just one over a
row
right so acoustic wave pressure drops by
one over the distance
and the dependency on the angle
bearing or or DOA is given by this kind
of like complicated looking expression
which has this mysterious function J1 in
it and J1 is called the bezel function
of the first kind of order one it's
extremely you know
a useful function in a lot of you know
communication Theory and and and other
fields but basically J1 is given by this
this integral here so your angle
dependency is determined by a bezel
function and your range dependency is
just one over range for the acoustic
wave that you generate at some
observation Point row and and Theta okay
well this is just math I think let's
let's look at some uh you know um
visualizations of what this actually
looks like here is just a recap of what
we talked about so at some observation
Point are your far field beam pattern is
basically given by this expression Alpha
is just a constant a squared is the
square of the the radius of your
aperture so that's a measure of its area
basically f is the frequency rho is the
distance to your observation point from
your emitter and this thing to J of you
know Norm k a sine Theta over Norm k a
sine Theta is your angle dependency this
is the important term actually that that
we're gonna focus on in the next few
slides because we want to know how as a
function of angle your basically beam
pattern changes okay
now let's look at a plot of uh of our
basically beam pattern this function
that that we found uh we're plotting it
at a fixed distance just as a function
of theta right so perhaps it's easier to
look at the bottom plot first so if this
is your circular disk that is emitting a
acoustic wave
and then you're looking at some fixed
distance from it doesn't matter what it
is but the distance we just want to take
it out of out of the picture and just
see as a function of angle how the the
acoustic wave pressure changes you get
this interesting you know
flower looking pattern which has a lot
of the energy as you see is concentrated
in what we call the main lobe
right and that's basically how you're
directing most of the acoustic wave
you're directing it into the main lobe
and then you have a little bit you know
kind of in in the side lobes at at
higher angles
so the main lobe it's
it has uh it's between two angles plus
and minus Theta zero
and you can actually find what exactly
Theta 0 is the expression is given in
the previous slide it's arc sine of
this which is some constant times the
speed of of sound divided by a times f
okay what's really really insightful
here is what do we want if we want to
make a sensor you want to direct most of
your acoustic energy in a tight beam
right because then you can basically
point it at different parts of the scene
kind of like a laser pointer except it's
acoustic waves and then the echo that
you get you kind of know it's coming
from the direction that your your
acoustic wave was was pointed at so you
want Theta 0 to be small
right for sensing applications obviously
not for
um like if you're if you're making a a
audio speaker you probably don't want
Theta 0 small right you want everybody
to hear what the speaker accepted for
some specific application you want your
speaker to be directional speakers you
want them wide right sensors you want
your emitter to be nice and tight so you
want small Theta zero
how do you get a small Theta zero so you
want basically this number to be small
right because that's the argument in the
arc sign so how do you make that small
either you need a large a so you need a
large aperture right or you increase
your f
that's so go to higher frequencies and
the point I made earlier Which is higher
frequency means better angular
resolution that's directly coming from
here because as you make your frequency
higher and higher your radiation pattern
or your beam pattern becomes you know
more directional you can get maybe
something like that which is at higher
frequencies or bigger bigger apertures
right
um
so uh this this trade-off actually that
to get higher resolution you need either
bigger emitters bigger apertures or
higher frequencies here we derived it
for acoustic waves you would see the
exact same thing happens at RF
frequencies and Optical frequencies this
is kind of like one of those universal
laws of physics that if you want higher
resolution more focused beams no matter
how you're generating your waves is it
acoustic wave or RF wave or or Optical
frequencies either you need to go to
high frequencies or you need larger
sources and and that's always the case
even in photography if you're into
photography you know like to get to get
higher resolution you need bigger lenses
you know with bigger apertures because
then you can get a tighter focus light
interior sensor which is a Sharper Image
higher resolution right so so this is I
hope by now kind of at least for the
acoustic waves you know where this is
coming from it's actually coming from
the solutions to the wave equation with
with the approximations that that we did
okay does this make sense so far
I hope it does okay
so going back to where we started we
said the principle of operation is the
emitter transmits a wave it hits a
Target and Echo comes back and then you
need to process the echo to find the
range and and the bearing angle we
talked about the forward path so far
right so we know exactly when the
emitter generates a wave for a given
emitter geometry what does that
radiation pattern or beam pattern look
like specifically if I were to you know
draw it here it actually looks like
something like this as a function of
angle
right
and then there is a one over range also
Decay
as as it propagates
one thing to note by the way in in this
plot here this is actually I'm showing a
cross section here but it's actually 3D
right so this this main lobe and all the
side lobes these actually look like
teardrops if you will right so they your
Theta you know there is there is
rotational symmetry in this and we're
just looking at the slice of it but the
actual beam goes you know it's it's like
this elongated
teardrop that propagates in the 3D space
okay so now we want to look at what the
reflected Echo is going to be because
that is what you receive and you need to
process to be able to determine your
time of flight and and bearing angle so
we have looked at the forward path now
we need to model what happens as it hits
the target and propagates back to the
receiver it turns out that it's super
simple actually it's all a few steps
that you need to do first we make an
approximation that the targets for now
are small compared to the wavelength
right so if you are dealing with small
targets almost like Point reflectors
what happens is that the echo from the
target you can model that as a spherical
wave
because it's a tiny Target you hit it
with a wave and what it echoes back it's
a spherical wave and as we know for
spherical waves the amplitude is
proportional inversely proportional to
the travel distance right so from this
unit we can say that from the target
Echo back to the receiver there should
be like a one over row Decay Factor if
we model our Target as a small no almost
like a point source
um
then it turns out that most of the
emitters
used in uh sonar sensing they can also
operate as receivers I mean that's also
true about you know uh audio speakers
you know if you give it a signal that
aperture vibrates and generates it a way
for you if you hit it with an acoustic
wave and that vibrates the the aperture
it will generate a signal for you so
every speaker can also be a microphone
and and the other way around if you will
and and
for that reason uh the the emitters are
are usually called transducers because
they they operate both ways they can
transmit for you and they also can
receive Echoes back for you
and if you have one of these which
operates as a transmitter and a receiver
if you have a transducer then um by by
the reciprocity of the the physics of
the environment it means that the
sensitivity pattern of your receiver to
the echo
is also governed by the exact same beam
pattern that we found especially in
terms of the angle right so if s of
theta is the sensitivity of your
receiver to an echo that's coming from
an angle Theta just because it's the
same as the as the transmitter that
function is also exactly given by this
bezel function and that's just by by
basically the reciprocity of the of the
physics there's a gamma here which is
some normalization constant doesn't
matter for our analysis but how
sensitive the receiver is to Echoes
coming at from different doas it is
given by the exact same radiation
pattern of the of the of the transmitter
because the transmitter and the receiver
are the same
uh finally there is this gain factor of
the of the transducer which is basically
how much of the echo energy you capture
right so the echo was coming from some
angle your angle sensitivity is given by
this function but also the bigger the
the receiver aperture more of the echo
energy you would capture okay so we have
this gain factor which is proportional
so it's zero some some constant times a
squared so it's proportional to the area
of your transducer that's your gain
Factor right so to find the echo all we
need to do is stack these basically
three effects that we just talked about
so what happens is that if P sub e of
rho n Theta is the echo amplitude that
you have received from a Target at some
range row and some bearing angle Theta
what happens is that you first hit it
with your transmitted
uh acoustic wave that we already solved
for right that's P of row and Theta
some fraction of That acoustic wave is
reflected back to you the fraction let's
say it's Delta it's a number between
zero and one right that's kind of like
the brightness if you will of the Target
in in acoustic wave right that's how how
much it reflects back then there is a
one over row term that's coming from
assumption number one which is a small
Target it's echoing back a spherical
wave so there's going to be a one over
rho Decay as it comes in the return path
as it comes from the target to the
receiver then at the receiver you
multiply by your sensitivity as a
function of theta which is given by this
function and your gain which is
basically some constant times the area
of your receiver plug everything in
right all of these we now know if you
plug everything in your final Echo that
you receive at your receiver is given by
this this big ugly expression here
what's important is you know the
dependencies it depends on one over
distance squared and by the way we have
not factored in acoustic attenuation
like stokes's law we have ignored it for
now we are assuming even in a lossless
medium you still get a 1 over rho
squared and that's just by conservation
of energy you get a one over rho squared
drop and the equal amplitude that you
get it's linear in frequency
it's proportional to the fourth power of
the the radius of your aperture and then
the angle dependency is basically this
Square
sorry I crossed it off but there's a
square here remember because in the
forward path you get it once and then in
the return path you get it in the S so
you get the square of that bezel bezel
function basically so now we know we
have we have solved the full physics you
know for a given aperture that is a
circular disk what is and a Target that
is at some range row and some angle
Theta what is the echo that the receiver
receives from the target I think this is
a good place to stop and then next time
we talk about how do you process this
received Echo to actually do ranging
bearing estimation and finally mapping
any questions
yes
great question so the question is if the
transmitter and the receiver are the
same it's one transducer so does it
transmit and then stop and listen or
does it continuously transmit it has to
stop and listen right otherwise it
interferes with it itself so when you
have a transducer that is like a
transmitter and a receiver it trans it
sends a pulse and then it listens for
the echo it waits for all the Echoes for
it to die off and then it sends the next
one we'll talk about it next time but
that's a great question